hello I'm Andre welcome to Berlin to the
PI data conference and to my talk here I
will talk to you about visualizing fact
inch dad and first question you will
probably have is pocketing start what is
that so translated it is ask the state
and it's a in general freedom of
information portal which helps people to
make Freedom of Information request to
the state and to give you more two
examples for example you might have
heard or let's say you heard about a
manager of Deutsche Bank giving his
birthday celebration in the Chancellor
house and you know the Chancellor house
is a public body so it belongs to the
state so and this event is probably
documented in this public body and so
what you can do is you can ask for the
guest list of this event and that's what
people do the manager you may know him
is use of a common it was a big deal at
that time and so this website help
people to make make it easy to send this
request and they even like implemented a
one click request so that you could go
on the website and just mmm yeah I have
this guest list sent to you another
example is a pretty smart high school
student that had his final exams and he
thought well exams they're kind of also
public documents so maybe I could ask
for them and so he did that and he even
received them but only after the exam so
yeah you see it's a pretty useful
website and um yeah now in this talk
what I want to talk about is what kind
of data do we have on this website what
are these requests made of then I want
to tell you how I got this data how I
try to organize it to make
more useful or to handle better and the
main part will be about how I visualize
it and how you can ask questions to this
data set and then in the end because I
still have many questions or many things
that I want to do with it I will tell
you about that and that will be it yeah
so first how did I get the data now what
kind of data oh I missed the first point
cool so what kind of data do we have so
we have a collection of Freedom of
Information requests and each request
consists of all the messages that went
between public body and the user usually
it's the case that so this website sends
automatically an email to the public
body and usually the public body sends a
male back to the user which he has to
scan and then uploads to the website but
in the end you have the whole process
transparent on the website and so other
informations are of course like which
public body was request sent to and what
is the current status of this request or
if it was already completed what was the
result wasn't successful or was the
information out there or other outcomes
and also for all the messages we have
the time stems so we can look for
example at response times of the public
bodies so in summary we have about
10,500 public Freedom of Information
requests and potentially they can go to
11,000 public bodies in Germany and and
this website started in 2011 so we have
kind of about the time range of five
years where we have data from and also
for each of the messages we have the
state the current status and if it was
the last message the result yeah ok so
now we know what kind of data we expect
and how do we get it so fortunately the
website offers the API over which you
can request all the requests and also
the public bodies and the messages I
gave you an example URL I won't show to
you so what you get there is a raw JSON
file with all the information of the
request and so yeah you just write a for
loop and then you can download the whole
data set so for this for now i just
downloaded all the data offline and yeah
analyze it offline but mmm later i also
want to embed this in the website i'm
also working with the team of artists
are together but this is a future issue
okay and so now we have the raw data in
a format of JSON files so how did I
organize it well short answer would be I
use pandas and this is a really cool
site because it's probably like eighty
percent of my work but I just send it up
in some bullet points so what I had to
do was ya get the JSON file into
dictionaries and then loaded into a data
frame that was a few lines i guess but
then you have to clean the data you have
to yeah make sure that you have standard
data formats in all of your data frame
columns and also there are many IDs and
links to other yeah file formats and
that you have to map to meaningful names
so that you can yeah visualize them
better and because it's really big data
set I had to first remove all the legal
texts because what the website does it
is it is adding all the legal text that
you would usually have to include in
your freedom of information request so
like what user usually does it it he
says
partially okay i want this document but
in the end the email will be like a lot
of legal text and then one line or so
please send me these documents so you
have to get rid of that stuff and yeah
but in the end you have a nice data
frame with which you can work and now we
can already come to visualizing data and
so like in general what I did was yeah
filter the data set to get the data the
parts of the data that I want and to
format it in a nice way the grouping
functionality of pandas are very useful
there because then you can group the
request by the public bodies or also the
states of Germany and and yeah compare
these and yeah then you can create the
raw plots and customize them with a mud
pot lip that's what I did ok so now we
have all these tools so to say but now
let's ask some questions to this data
set because that's what I'm really
interested in and so first a broad
question would be did the website maybe
have an influence on the total number of
requests so this law for freedom of
information in Germany exists since 2006
and here I plotted the total number on
the y-axis over the years and so 2006
was the first year and what you see that
for the first five years it was kind of
stable at like below 2000 requests per
year and then in 2011 [ __ ] start
started and yeah since then I would
rather I would say the number quite
increased and what I also showed here is
what fraction of the request is going to
the Ministry of Finance's because as you
can see in 2012 there are so many
request only like half of the requests
are going to the Ministry of Finance and
we found out that these are serial
requests to the Ministry made by lawyers
that were getting data for their
customers in lawsuits yeah so you can
already see that data is revealing some
interesting details but requests so next
question was are these requests in
general successful so how many requests
are you are getting actually the
information that they are asking for and
here I'm showing you in the percentage
on the y-axis and you can see the this
okay so you can see that about fifty
percent of the requests were either
successful or partially successful
partially meaning that yeah at least the
part of the data set or the information
was given to the user and what you can
also see is like about ten percent are
like refused or the information is not
even there and but also a big part then
you see this in many public bodies also
a big part of the requests are falling
asleep so that can mean that the public
body is not answering for quite some
time um I think threshold is in them the
moment at six months and but it can also
mean that the user like the public body
was asking the user for more details
about information but the user I don't
know didn't have interests anymore or
something like that um yeah so what
overall I would say the requests are ya
rattus Castle each second request gets
his information more or less yeah for so
for this kind of result you can now go
and group together the request
republic body or for the different
states in germany unfortunately i'm not
showing it here but yeah mmm so that
would be maybe motivation to join this
project okay so next question how long
does the public body need to respond the
law says that it should answer within a
month which is like about 30 days it
depends on the holidays in between and
so what you can use see is actually the
book of the public bodies or the
requests are answered within this legal
time limit but there's also many more
that are you are responding much much
later I have to say about this data that
it's not that easy to calculate because
yeah you would have to look at each
single message what is the reason that
the message was like resolved because
like these are completed requests and
the user decides when the request is
completed so yeah it's rather difficult
to be sure that the request is release
completed yeah you might wonder what
where this peak here comes from so in
the beginning of this year the website
started campaign because there was a
decision by yeah by a court by the
federal court that the scientific
service of the Parliament which is
always generating reports for the
parliament has to give out these reports
if people are requesting them by Freedom
of Information requests and so what we
were doing of course is asking for the
list of all these reports that the
scientific service is
making and did in the last 20 years so
what the people of the project did was
yeah offering like a list where you just
click on one of the documents and an
automatic email would be sent and then
Freedom of Information request would be
made so like when within a week I think
there were about 2,000 Freedom of
Information requests which the public
body usually answers by mail so they
were pretty overwhelmed by a lot of
requests and then without mentioning
these campaign this campaign they just
said okay from now and we're giving them
or making them publicly accessible from
ourselves so yeah that was quite a
success and I think this not this is
here all this request that they answered
after yeah mmm deciding that they will
make them public anyway okay so you can
see there are ya many questions that you
can ask the data is just scratched the
surface of all the insights that you can
get from the data and so what else can
you do what I thought about this natural
language processing because you have all
these messages like there are emails by
the public body are also from the user
and for example you could ask maybe the
user yeah it's not asking very politely
for the information and maybe this is
this has an effect on the success rate
of the request or you could look how
generic the text of the public bodies
are because usually I guess they use
just text puppets and include all right
you know insert the names of the user
and also you can maybe find correlations
or different differences between
different states or like maybe the
success rate depends on the size of the
city where the request is made or also
on how many people are actually working
for this
Freedom of Information requests yeah so
there's a lot of stuff to do yeah and in
conclusion I can say by using Python I
was able to ask a few questions about
this interesting data set which is yeah
showing the transparency process in the
German state and in general I can I
guess you can say that by using python
by using data analysis you can risa part
open democracy and make a governmental
process is more transparent and yeah I
guess there's a lot more stuff to do so
if you're interested feel free to join
the code that I wrote is on this github
page maybe give me some time to make the
last with today because it's not up to
date and also the web page is here and
it's actually also on github and it's
implemented as a general framework for
freedom of information portals and it's
implemented in Django so they're
actually also looking for people that
helped in the development of that and
yeah that should be it thanks for your
attention and feel free to ask
how did i get rid of what stuff oh there
was a rather rough cleaning so I didn't
go okay i will repeat the question he
asked if maybe in the question there are
quotes or stuff like that so in the text
of the request yeah I didn't I didn't
analyze the text of the request by
cleaning I just meant yeah make uniform
data formats like strings around that
stuff so yeah yeah he asked to show how
it works I was so [ __ ] sad d and it
is linked but i'm not sure if i have
internet no yeah um but with what
so you're asking how to make a request
on the website actually okay so this is
the starting page of the website and
here it gives actually video how the
process is working and also what the
steps of the requests are and so first
you have to log in and then yeah you
click on this button to make a request
so the first thing you have to do is to
choose the public body I don't know if
somebody has a example or some something
that he wants to ask for so he said we
should ask the Berlin Senate for the
bicycle lanes and so here now it gives
you some advice what you should consider
when making the request and yeah mmm
things so now I chose this public body
here and usually what you want to do is
send a Freedom of Information request so
enjoyment in from itunes fights and fog
and so i choose this one and now yeah
you can write something
so now here I would just say the
documents of the plans for the bicycle
lanes in Berlin for 2016 or something
like that yeah I wouldn't write it in
english of course and so I'm not making
it here but yeah so if you wrote it here
that's already it you have to register
before that is that's what I already did
now you have see my address but if you
checked everything you just click on
this button and then the request is made
and email is sent to the public body
yeah of course yeah so for example with
this scientific service there were a lot
of finding examples but it was for what
a funny what people in the parliament
were asking the scientific service so
there was there were people asking if
there exists life in outer space you
know something like that so they are
very curious I guess that's positive I'm
yeah there was the report you can so
what they actually did after this
campaign they setup page which is called
the good often which has all the reports
and there you can yeah search through us
you can fold it to a full text search
through all the reports that this
scientific service made so i think it
was about this
yeah so here the first report says the
European Union and her dealing with the
issue unidentified flying objects so
it's gonna be fortune yeah so he asked
for best practices when visualizing the
data and I guess like preparing the
figures for this presentation for
example right yeah so I guess like a few
rules that you always can consider it
like make large fonts always say what's
on the axis of your plots and i don't
know like use nice colors and select
that you have a nice contrast between
things that you want to compare or let
where there is a contrast that you want
to show yeah that's what I can think of
I don't know do you have more specific
question about that or okay yeah
hmm he asked so he asked how I make sure
if i clean the data that i did it
correctly and so what I usually do is
yeah I write the code and then let it
run and I just check for some examples
that I guess are like yeah mmm good good
examples for this kind of procedure yeah
I don't go through all day data yeah
yeah so she asked why how did I come to
this project more or less and it's
rather the second that you said so I was
at the net put it on net politics
conference last year that was another
scandal about this treason from like the
treason lawsuit for an extra tick boom
talk it's like a German net politics
blog or website so that was like the big
scandal and then I got interested in the
subject then I went to the conference
and there the guy that is running this
the website was giving a talk and then I
thought well that's very interesting and
they were actually discussing this issue
with a scientific service and it was not
resolved at that time and then I thought
they could probably use some help and I
want to like apply my just learn Python
skills so I asked them yeah if they have
some tasks and yeah then we found out
that there's a lot of stuff that you can
do with the requests
thank you